-Nice to see you again.
We have so much to talk about.
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm so happy to be here
with you.
-Please, thank you
for coming back.
Last time we talked
was right before you won
a Grammy and an Oscar
for "Fight For You."
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you.
-From "Judas and
the Black Messiah."
I mean, wow,
you have an Oscar.
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-What was the night
like for you?
Did you just --
-Oh, my gosh, it was amazing.
And they only let you
bring one guest.
So, it was not craziness
like most awards show times
because of COVID.
And it was just me and my mom,
and she was so excited.
We got to meet everybody.
It was chill.
Angela Bassett came up to us.
She was like, "Oh, my gosh!
Is this your mom?"
[ Cheers ]
"This is crazy."
And Zendaya presented you
with your Oscar,
and she did
a little jump for joy.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You guys must know each other,
I'm assuming.
-Yeah, actually, we both grew up
in the Bay Area.
And I met her when we were kids
'cause we were supposed to be
in a band together,
which is super random.
[ Laughter ]
But we ended up
not being in a band together,
and then, years later,
we see each other, and, yeah.
It's like a reunion.
-At the Oscars.
Oh, my God, yeah.
And now where do you have
the Oscar?
Is it next to your Grammys?
Where do you put it?
-It's funny, I keep it
on my dining table
so when people come into
my house, they're like,
"Is that...real?
[ Laughter ]
"Is that...?"
I'm like, "Yeah, pick it up.
It's heavy."
-That's exactly right.
Is it really heavy?
-Yes, it is.
It's super heavy.
-I'll never know.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Grammys,
you're nominated this year
for your work on Mary J. Blige's
album, "Good Morning Gorgeous."
-Yeah, that was awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I love Mary J. Blige.
But this is -- you worked on --
actually, that song,
and produced the -- co-wrote
and produced that song with her.
And she's one of your idols,
you said?
-Yeah, one of
my favorite artists.
I grew up listening
to Mary J. Blige.
I used to sing her songs
on piano.
And it's just, like, crazy that
I even got the opportunity
to work with her, so...
-How did you get into Mary J.
when you're going up?
-It was my mom.
You know, she was
going through some stuff,
so she would listen to it.
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't understand it
at the time, but I get it now.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you also were listening
to Lenny Kravitz, Alicia Keys,
Stevie Wonder.
And I just saw that
you actually performed
with all of those people.
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-What is it like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is it like
to share the stage
with all these artists
that you were inspired by?
-I mean, it's insane.
Like, these are people
I grew up watching
and listening,
and the fact that
they show me so much love,
and I got to perform with them,
it's nerve wracking but also
just, like, confirmation.
Like, I'm exactly
where I'm supposed to be.
-Yeah.
You are.
You're where
you're supposed to be, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Can we talk about
"Beauty and the Beast"?
-Yes.
-You can add this now
to your résumé.
-I know, I'm a Disney Princess!
-You're a Disney Princess.
Exactly right! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Here's a picture of you as Belle
right there.
This is -- This is one of
my favorite Disney cartoons.
I love it. I mean, this is
pre-Pixar and Lin-Manuel.
"Beauty and the Beast" was --
that's my jam.
Was this a dream for you
to be a princess?
-Absolutely.
It was definitely, like,
something I imagined to be
as a kid,
but you never really think
it could happen.
So, I'm walking
a little different.
I'm talking a little different.
[ Laughter ]
-You are.
-You know?
-You also go
by your real name in this.
It's Gabriella Wilson.
-Yeah.
-When you're doing a new thing
or you're acting,
you want to go by that name?
-Yeah, you know,
for a long time,
I was in the shadows.
And I really wanted people
to focus on the music.
And now that I'm doing
other things,
I feel like it's time for people
to get to know the person
behind the music.
-Yeah.
I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What can everyone expect
when they watch this,
"Beauty and the Beast"?
-It's exactly what it's called,
a celebration.
You know, this is the
anniversary -- 30 years.
So, it's gonna be live-action.
Of course, with me
and the most amazing cast.
Martin Short, who's here.
-Yeah, come on.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Applause ]
-David Alan Grier, Rita Moreno,
Josh Groban.
-Josh Groban I saw
is in it, too.
-Yeah.
Shania Twain.
-Yes! Oh, I know that!
[ Cheers ]
-It's crazy.
But it's gonna be
the cartoon and then
into the live-action.
And it's just gonna be
a beautiful celebration.
We're gonna celebrate
the creation of it.
-Yeah.
I have another close-up picture
of you looking gorgeous
as Belle.
-Thank you.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-I wanted to
show a clip tonight,
but we don't actually
have a clip.
But we do have a ukulele.
-Oh!
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I was just wondering...
if you wouldn't mind giving --
Could you maybe give us
a little taste?
-Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
Let's see.
Let's see what I can do.
♪♪
♪ Certain as the sun ♪
♪ Rising in the East ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Tale as old as time ♪
♪ Song as old as rhyme ♪
♪ Beauty and the Beast ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-H.E.R., everybody!
"Beauty and the Beast:
A 30th Celebration"
airs December 15th
at 8:00 p.m., on ABC.
Mary McCartney
joins us after the break.
Stick around.
I tried!